sorgen ja bitte
[Musik]
da ist
ja gute moral gut
ja sehr gut
wichtig wäre hier intensität nach wir
sind jetzt auch wieder mal in sich
gefangen tänzler gerichte sind jetzt
thema im gericht also ausrichtende
jährige schaffens ist heißt es dass er
geistig momentan richten können
das wort und den satz sie zum team der
zürcher jemand einen anderen anwalt auch
sagen er war eine person wird auf eine
andere sagen bindet die blinde wut die
haben nicht der fall
der zorn der engram sandras aber er
scheint mir auch ganz gerecht
reisedaten wieder auf
[Musik]
wichtig sind
ich habe es jetzt gar nicht richtig
verstanden was die dann tragen sie haben
tragen messer und sieht sehr schneiden
damit menschen die mobil
[Musik]
also raus
wer besser
diese
das ist
[Musik]
ja ich nehme dieses gut also vorn hat
auch so ein bisschen als blinde ist in
dem sinne würde ich sagen dass man dort
auch unbeherrschten und insofern passte
blieben gut wieder zusammen
[Musik]
selber
sich eben andere energie
[Musik]
ja ich könnte niemals denn sie bringen
ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher fliegt
des phänomens treffen sich strukturiert
ist ich glaube dass der zorn ist eine
reaktive halt ist die reaktion ist und
ich glaube in so viel aktivität
desjenigen 12
dann haben habe ich zwar schon genau das
glaube ich auch als im zorn der bau auf
unseren zorn es auch immer augen metern
zu errichten
ich könnte vielleicht auch dann
irgendwann seien auf eine person sein
weil ich eigentlich bin
dies könnte auch immer gewollt ist das
heißt die skulptur der internationalität
richter mit der reflexion ist der letzte
punkt einer reflexion einer streckung
[Musik]
steigert was dann zum aus aber ich
glaube da ist nicht nur von ihm zum
ausbruch kommen hier sehen sie müssten
ganzen rattenschwanz davor liegt ba1
solche moralische bremen will nämlich
einfach bis ins tal punkte sehen sind da
sie immer schauen was für darauf hin wir
sind ausgebildet und fest ist nicht nur
seine reaktionen sind es sind
aufwendungen von reflexionen von andere
laster die dann auch manchmal im
zusammenspiel ist diese energie erhalten
dann auch nicht so sehr auf die energie
sozusagen schauen sollte er sich auf
diese kühle reflexion
[Musik]
serien
wir haben ja diese augen
ja
[Musik]
mir scheint nicht die zeit sie haben es
auch zugeschrieben dass das eine
erzählung so negativ mit beteiligten
also das interpretiere ich so wenn es
noch mal passiert musik zu
interpretieren und dann nämlich
gerechtfertigt sind oft richtig und dann
wird man natürlich auch häufig
unbeherrscht als der zorn kann dann im
endeffekt seien aber ich glaube nicht
dass wir dem vom ende her ziehen sollten
sie mir am anfang eher heranwächst und
motiviert und irgendwann sie die gründe
so stark dass dann vielleicht jemand aus
als unbeherrscht halten auf jeden fall
auch im moment ihren
[Musik]
da habe ich was kann er nicht nur
sinnvoll
mehr
statt
beim 1
sein
nicht
gut mehr als sie weisen zu recht darauf
hin dass viele dieser todsünden nicht
den handlungs aspekt ein
also sagt man sich also die motivation
was in meinem kopf vorgeht ist es nicht
meine sache
die landfrauen darf sich nicht noch
nachempfinden zu sagen ich mich zu haben
dafür so mein ziel ist es ja beim zorn
bin ich mir nicht sicher ich glaube aber
auch den winter sondern dann
manifestiert ist der zorn häufigsten
gewissen 250 den kranken aber eher träge
macht
ich glaube ich nicht sagen ich glaube
tatsächlich dass er hier über der
handlungszeit weggerutscht aber die
frage ist berechtigt
gibt es vielleicht auch immer man könnte
es in dem überhaupt sorgen findet kann
ich alles entstand zufällig gelesen habe
profitiert und das war wieder da müssen
wir uns auch fonds ist in die rechte der
bürger hat jetzt einfach nicht nein
fertig
[Musik]
richtig ernst genommen
nachdem vergeben sie auch unter anderem
zur folge
[Musik]
ja
sie trägt ihr aber nicht als bruder und
ich glauben das sind doch in den süden
bis in den westen hin ist sich die
britinnen man sich also in meiner
ökonomie der seele in eine emotionsfreie
dass ich da etwas durcheinander bringen
und dass das auch als problematisch ist
weil es auch der grund sein könnte film
tatsächlich schlecht handlungen aber es
entspringt aus einem ungleichgewicht
dass ich ihm sagen wir müssen jetzt bis
weitergehen mein leben gern spannende
sachen wir haben nicht gezeigt was ist
das das ist auch eine ganz tolle sehen
es auch wieder hier
sie können ja ausrechnen wie ich bin ich
dann genau so werden hier kommt jetzt
der zaun der kommilitonen habe völlig
recht dass der vorlesung halten
bei der beute wusste wurden im voraus
liegt nämlich so das ist nicht pop wurde
geschwollenen kam haben sie noch so
symbole die das noch besonders
veranschaulichen ja ganz genau
ja spiegel und auch ein bisschen
eigentlich halte es muss genau
also ich glaube dass die rücken mut der
unmut dass der superstar verschiedene
andere und runde mit hineinspielen als
narziss muss bestimmt leitl kann als
würden sie da sind auf rogans
florencia ja auch arroganz denke ich
diesen als arroganz als ich jedes thema
mangelnder respekt verachten missachten
wir sind ja und die wir im verlauf bis
sie mir denke dass die auch auf den
hochmut zum spielen oder mit ihm
zumindest eng verwandt gibt es noch
etwas was ihnen hier auffällt spiegel
haben wir zweimal mindestens einmal hier
einmal seltsam gewesen was sich da
betrachtet
ja also hier werden noch so opfer gab da
gebracht ich werde mich ganz schön weil
der spiegel ist da stand der mächtigsten
was mir jetzt noch so käme wäre in der
biblischen tradition dieser turmbau zu
haben wo die menschen wirklich sich
riesengebäude und wollten das wie sich
jetzt ein bisschen das hält lebt sie
noch reingepasst ok
[Musik]
eigentlich
wie sich dazu verhalten
ja ich denke wollen sie gleich dazu
[Musik]
entsteht rauben oder als sich die spinne
wurde sondern die mutter
auch eigenen
immer noch
ganz toll
aber eigentlich selber einen verein
[Musik]
also gut aussieht und verweisen sieben
folgen ist also ein bisschen das muss
korrigiert und ich glaube dass der
unterschied folgende ist im narzissmus
bis man ihr plus also der zins
finanzierten hat man sich ein loch war
das immer gestopft werden muss soll man
man hat einfach ehrlich kein halt und
versucht das kompensieren durch
einigkeit und so weiter ich glaube dass
hier was ist was die jeweilige person an
sich selbst hessen während der hochmut
wie meinen augen über die tendenz sich
eben auch über andere zu erheben
also eben auch nach auszugeben und sehr
aktiv zu werden ich glaube dass nazismus
immer das must read sich die person sich
selbst sie kommt nicht von sich weg und
im hofgut erhebt sich die person über
andere
sie kommen von sich weg es mag ja auch
nazismus eine rolle spielen aber ich
glaube es ist noch mehr aber sie sagt
eine spiegelung das passt auch hier
wieder diese spiegel ein es geht immer
um selbstbild und fremdbild stimmt
überein und außen wahrnehmen
selbst ein missverhältnis dieser diese
sachen
[Musik]
genau nicht ja
genau ja genau wir müssen unsere ich ins
vereinbarten gilt diese per die als die
schlimmste der 7 nach der sitzung
was ist der grund leider haben sie mich
den punkt jemand wenn sie mal an die
schöpfungsgeschichte im paradies paris
sie wollten sein wie gott bei der bauen
dass erkenntnisse warum das leben
sondern also erkennen können sie aber es
ja nicht liegen
man muss sich was anderes als das was
einem eigentlich gar nicht gebührt das
ist ja auch noch enthalten natürlich
kann das darauf hinweisen dass man so
ein gesundes maß einfach überschreitet
hochmut führt dazu standen eine
teilnahme da sind sich selbst oder die
eigenen bedürfnisse in den vordergrund
stellten damit ihr dazu neigt andere zu
vernachlässigen oder um geld das wir
hatten ja man stellt sich immer ins
zentrum ja das habe ich auch aus den
egoismus muss man maß an andere urteilen
zu können oder eben auch sich eine
position zu bringen
die eigentlich gar nicht zusteht wenn
gar nicht gebührt sehr selbst zentriert
und ich glaube eben der patient die nuts
ist in die dreht sich nur um sich selbst
man kann es gibt sicherlich auch dem
phänomen des narzissmus das phänomen
jetzt mit der instrumentalisierung dass
aldi narzissten häufig auch andere
menschen eher instrumenten
vier särge missbrauchen aber ich glaube
dass das was anderes ist als der der
stadt noch am nächsten ist verdeutlicht
auch bei dem wilden kreaturen natürlich
dagegen
so könnte man das interpretieren steckt
sich also ich weiß ob es das selbe ist
auf jeden fall steckt ein wesen den kopf
in den sand
das stimmt auf jeden fall alles ist es
scheint sich irgendwie von sich zu
verbergen des anderen lesen was im halb
so viel schnee stecken er hat so jahres
genauso ich glaube es eine rüstung und
herren was ihm und gab es eine klammer
die ihm den mund zuhält
das ist alles sehr verspielt also das
ist die schlimmste jetzt im tod sind und
es gibt sie noch natürlich nach einem
dessert hängen so forderte sie ist
[Musik]
wo es immer um die luxuria oder
unkeuschheit es ist ein schreibt man
eine teilnehmerin dass neben dem hochmut
ein selbstbildnis verzehrt wird wo man
sich selbst überschätzt das ist
sicherlich richtig dass man das eigene
eigene weltbild das selbstbild was noch
nicht konstruiert ist an sich ist
betonte dass das konstruktionen sind
konzeptionell selbst dass sie dann
korrigieren wir in einer anderen welt
und das aus dieser kollision heraus
daneben gewaltpotenzial entstehen wenn
ihr mir ein selbstbild entwickelt was zu
konstruiert ist und das gesunde maß
verlassen hat dann kann es in 14
konfrontationen wenn wir wieder stellen
in den wgs gesetzt werden dann auch
zuzuhören kommen oder zu solchen sachen
ok in keuschheit wo ist was haben wir
hier also hier sehen wir natürlich ganz
gerade das geschlechtliche besonders
betont wir sehen sie jetzt einen eine
sechste darstellung ein fabelwesen eine
frau ja angeht sage ich jetzt mal
sie sehen aber auch hier dass uns ein
fabelwesen ein bestimmtes sein
hinterteil zeigt und ihr ein vogel kann
es nicht lassen
seinen schnabel einem echten vorteil sie
explizit werden mit auf bestimmte
körperteile besonders fokussiert hier
oben scheinen dieser kugel ist recht
sehe ja und hier ganz miteinander
verkehren
ja man sieht sehr viele tierische
hinterteil
ja ja ja
gibt es da noch zu kämpfen am baum der
früchte vielleicht lust hat natürlich
jetzt sehe ich unser weg das ist
natürlich hier zum dargestellt dass es
auch um mäßigkeit ist dass hier etwas
aus dem ruder sich eine übertriebene wie
hart games weiter ziel das
geschlechtliche übertrieben wird so und
das ist jüngste gericht das gab sein
selbst das gleich in die versammlung das
brot stand denjenigen geben
das ganze prozent aktivieren hier steht
wenige aktivitäten regelung entfernung
also kommt wir behalten das gleichen
dasjenige war ich meines vaters sagt
jesus und das leben des vaters ist
natürlich rein und unten besteht
bestätigt die htg team fort ihr über die
beamten in das ewige feuer meines vaters
sind die hölle
und hier müssen die ganze bank als
entweder es mit krippenspiel
ohne diesen schnitt eineinhalb millionen
die wahl zwischen okay das ist jetzt das
ist natürlich ein ganz klarer
theologischen ist das so und jetzt kennt
sie alle passieren können wir das
gewinnen sind 590 96 glaube ich so aus
kommt könnte das rennen setzten hier
gibt es ein paar haben das taktisch
alles passt das ist nicht wohl ist sehen
der türkei
dieser film handelt davon tasten 100
stets auch seven days sind ein mörder
menschen dafür tötet und auch in einer
solchen form tötet dass sie eben an
dieser tools mit selbst sterben also
dass da eine person dann so erschüttert
wird dass sie fast schon platz also da
wird eine person in der zustand der
todsünde präsenz oder an
zustande gebracht und so weiter ein
ziemlich brutaler film ich möchte
deswegen ja auch keinen sinn wir haben
höhere zuschauen aber leider nur sagen
diese motive der todsünden
die haben sich überall auch in der kunst
wir sehen uns ja schon an diesem bild
wenig sparen soll jetzt noch ganz kurz
auf diesen herren zum schluss alles und
wir haben ein paar live fragen die auch
in die nächste sitzung des studios noch
machen das tut ist der grundes
lasterhaften ein dienst wie verhalten
sich thun und laster zueinander
da sitzt du diese frage und gibt sie
nicht nur das erste noch die ersten noch
lesen können
ein bisschen spät eigentlich vorhanden
sein bei allem kontinuierlichen teil
waren kann einen größen einkleidung oder
einen gleichen betragen geben und dies
haben wir damit auch die selbst in der
mitte und das gleiche ist eine art
mittleres maison zwischen übermaß napoli
und mangeln
in waynes ich nenne aber das mittlere
der sachen das gleich weiter und beiden
extremen entfernt ist und das ist für
alle ein paar sind als wenn ich in der
strecke habe
wie gut es lieben
tns
der sache damit die magnetische mit dem
gewissen
worauf es alles dunkles hinaus möchte
ist dass die mädchen für uns nicht über
die arithmetische die mit ihrer sache
die kann ich außen ist die temperatur
zwischen nur gerade 5 aber was die mitte
für uns da ist etwas anderes gemeint ich
mit dem metern mit uns was weder zu viel
noch zu wenig ist dieses nicht eines der
ist auch nicht verraten
wenn zum beispiel zehn und zwei minister
nimmt man als das der sache mit einer 6
und daraus mit den gleichen betrag das
integrative kaufen wird das ist die
mitte macht der arithmetischen das
midler wenn dazu auch bones davon wieder
nicht zu nehmen wenn für jemanden
nahrung von zehn minen zu viel und
nahrung von zwei gehen so wenige szenen
dann wird der trainer nicht nur von 600
vorschreiben ist auch das wird die gegen
den euro auflösen familie und wenig sein
anfänger in athletischen die selbe gilt
für weg ausblick zeigt also wirkung
gegenüber mangel
das mittlere dagegen suchen eben dieses
jahr werden ihnen diese zahl ist aber
nicht der sache sein wird so auf uns ist
ganz wichtig also dass ein austariertes
ausbalanciertes es muss nicht immer das
arithmetische mittel seien und was auch
ganz wichtig mehr zeit scheint das geht
natürlich auch diskussionen dies mittel
für uns die gesunde moralische mit dem
bus aus geboten werden das ist also ein
prozess der das muss ich das kann ich
mich einfach mit dem mega markt messen
das muss ich auch sagen und das ist so
ein hinweis darauf dass ich glaube dass
tatsächlich das ganze mit der tour
beginnen die moral und die moral beginnt
mit der asymmetrie und erst im weg diese
asymmetrie im aus mitteln des gesunkenes
darin besteht also ich glaube dass diese
these ist mir jedenfalls sympathisch
dass sie nicht bei atom beginnen können
sie das video aber nur über und oben zu
stehen
ein itc und nicht andersrum die toten
handelt also ich glaube das erste ist
und hoben gedanken betont und nicht erst
rund 1 abschließen das ist also nach
unten gesetzt hatten
denn diese hat mit affekthandlung zuzug
oder diesen gibt es über mangel an das
bietet zb kann und furcht nun beginne
zwar mithalten alle immerhin lust und
unlust ebenso zu viel trainiert und weiß
es nicht der richtige preis dagegen sie
zu empfinden wenn man soll nicht an
dessen sich menschen gegenüber solchen
niemand soll ist das mit dem best dies
macht und aus ähnlich gibt es über
maßnahmen und das internet zum phantom
tag wieder fällt nun handeln dazu bei
denen das übermaß wie auch der mangel
eine verfehlung darstellen das mädchen
dagegen gewehrt und das richtig trifft
die ist beides aber gegenstand
sind kinder tun tun ist als eine art
mitte mit chelsea auf das nur lesend
ziel das mittlerweile für uns und nicht
das mit wolf und die sache sieht es aus
aber jetzt will ich immer noch ein
allerletztes ein beispiel in die liste
der angstsymptome und laster verbringe
solisten und das ist könnte man sagen
ist ein bisschen der vorläufer muss dort
genau diese situation als bei
aristoteles haben auf jeden fall würde
ich nur behaupten eine den ersten
ethischen aufstellungen auflisten der
und in bezug auf furcht vor boston ist
die tapferkeit andrea die mit wenigen
menschen die die mir überschreiten hatte
übermäßig fürchten uns keine eigene
bezeichnung das ist ein tag für tag wer
dagegen übermäßig modell empfehlen ist
teuer kühlen und wer sich zu sehr
fürchtet und zu wenigen mut ist viel los
hier geht es natürlich gut
die vielleicht nicht unbedingt erstmal
moralisch zu verstehen sind auch aber
das sind eher tugenden im sinne von
fähigkeiten und ist der letzte noch
da stehen welche wenn wir jetzt ja das
ist die chance auf weniger als fünf
stunden täglich punkt heißt einfach ganz
allein
gut sein taugliches zb hatte für die
antiken griechen auch der stift eine
tugend was ist die kunden des stiftes
gutzuschreiben lesbar zu schreiben wenn
der stiften leer jetzt hat er ein laster
hatte ein huhn hatte einen darf nicht so
viele haben das ja alles draußen also
tun meint der ideen das gut sein das ist
ein funktionales ein pferd hat auch
nicht dass man es eben dass man auch im
reiten kann oder ein messwagen caritas
schneiden kann das darf nur stumpf sein
und so ist erst mal jeden wolken zu
verstehen als in den sehr weiten der
nicht nur moralisch ist wir verstehen
heute tun in der regel war es total ist
nicht nur gut im sinne von brauchbar für
die jeweiligen und jetzt gibt es hier
noch dass das geben und nehmen von geld
geht ist die bedeckten die freigebigkeit
terry rodgers das übermaß und der mangel
verschwendung und behandeln hier zeigen
die leute bei mars und mangel auf
entgegengesetzten spender ist übermäßig
aus geben und nehmen zu wenig ehrgeizige
ist nur über weise im nehmen und
mangelhafte geben nämlich auf das geld
geht es noch weiter ins wasser
als mitte die großzügigkeit der
großzügig unterscheidet sich nämlich vom
freigiebigen jena hat mit großem diesem
kleinen beitritt das übermaß an dem man
in diesem fall geschmacklosigkeit und
trotz allem beim ausziehen
die mangel kleinigkeit diese form von
dieser maßnahme unterscheiden sich von
den bereichen der freigebigkeit wird
später einmal ist alles hier gibt es
eine ganze liste von wohltuenden und
meine thesen
mit auf den weg geben möchte lesen sie
sich noch mal durchchecken auch noch mal
die folien und überleben sie tatsächlich
von wo aus gehen denkt aristoteles die
tugend ich habe den verdacht er von rund
um mit beiden extremisten hin gemittelt
werden müssen aber ganz anders
dass man sagt es geht werte wie
gerechtigkeit denken sie an platon idee
das gute die liebe gerechtigkeit daten
bringt das ganze die mobilität von
perfektion zustand von der vollendung
tun und deswegen den mangel das laster
als deprivation als die verdunkelung
gysi dem erscheinen des aristoteles ein
bisschen anders werfen der
entgegengesetzten seite aus gibt von der
faktischen ungleichgewicht situation in
der wir uns befinden wir sind zerrissen
in verschiedene tendenzen und wir müssen
immer darum eines prozesses wer diese
instrumente finden wenn wir das nächste
gemacht haben dann kommen wir noch ein
bisschen auf thomas zu sprechen
er nehme ich hier ganz interessante
bemerkungen uns beliefert hat was er mit
den sieben haupt versteht wo wir wollen
das immer fragen wie sich diese von
thomas märklin ist ein mittelalterlicher
philosoph platz 15 ist zudem lastete
studios war und die wären dann immer
wieder auf dieselben punkte zu sprechen
kommen neid und das sind alles gibt
dieses sinne wünsche ich ihnen
wochenstart und bis zum nächsten